drive drive driving drive drive good
evening believe nation today I'm gonna
show you 10 ways that you can stay
driven being an actor is the first thing
that I remember wanting to do in life
I remember 1415 years old watching some
classic films not while spending months
and months watching all the great
classics all the great performers of the
past and being so incredibly inspired by
them and saying to myself one day I want
to come close to doing something that
good so that I think that that thirst or
that drive to just achieve what I
believe is something as good as you know
those heroes that I have is what
continues to make me want to want to do
this and the people that I see utilize
the power broke more than anybody at all
all the people that when they reach a
level of success they still use and
that's how they maintain this success
that hunger and drive and and and we
grew up at a time and age where it was
you need money to make money you got to
know somebody mm-hmm well I mean you
know look at me look at half this room
you know I grew up a you know
african-american short dyslexic got left
back one time almost got left back the
second time can can't dribble the
basketball can't sink and draw didn't
know anybody didn't go to college I
didn't stop me at all
yeah right yeah I had a I had a mother
that really loved me dearly and I had
some like minded fool partners and
friends who would never let me stop and
I never let them stop and I had a will
and a drive and and and I still have all
those same things I still rise and grind
every single morning the resistance to
your idea should do nothing but drive
you forward and and force you to really
hone in on your idea and give you energy
and if it actually holds you back and
makes you second-guess yourself then
maybe you shouldn't be doing it creating
a business is impossible at times it
feels impossible and so you really have
to be just so passionate about it
and you know really don't take no for an
answer if anything can like deviate you
from your patch then maybe it's it's not
necessarily the right one so make sure
it is what you want it to be stay
focused and and allow all that
resistance along the way to really give
you energy and fuel your engine to move
forward I feel like I love the process
of learning and discovering new things
so much and I love seeing other people
win so like learning these new ideas and
new skills that I never been exposed to
before and then being able to teach them
to other people and watch the aha
moments or the breakthroughs or the
progress happen for them I love seeing
other people win so that's what kept
driving me and I was like wow if I could
do this with five people I could do this
with like 20 people or a hundred people
or a thousand people then it was really
who's exciting are you money driven no
not at all used to be though because
used to be now I'm not what's the drug
now you want to get over how does a lot
of legacy now it's about what did I do
and how will I be remembered when it's
over what does it take coming out of you
what's inside you that enables you or
compels you to make films with such
relentless drive where in the world does
that come from it's I don't know it's
hard to say it's it's it comes from from
unready normal yeah well you never know
I mean if the demons weren't unleashed
through film I'd probably going be Leah
you know somewhere and there's a theory
on Thorazine you know know that I don't
think that's true I think it just has to
do with with how films that I liked it
and I remembered you know enjoying and
having that exhilaration hit me and I
want to transfer that back to other
people and just studying the craft and
learning how to do it and and the
special thrill as a filmmaker comes from
seeing an immediate audience response
now the only the only other thing the
only other sort of a genre or if it's
not even a genre but the only the only
other thing that has that effect in
films is comedy
and comedy is not my forte demonstrably
yet it innate earth and and there's some
comedy and in this film but for a film
to function as a comedy I think there's
a special magic there and I'm you know
I'm come creeping toward it but I'm not
sure I can do that but that's the that's
the other area where where you can look
at it at a sea of 700 faces and see them
all having the same reaction and you
know you're touching touching them
that's I mean I I'm not a performer I
can't stand up on a stage and tell jokes
or sing or do something that that
affects people directly
the closest thing for me is being able
to sit in the theatre and watch a
reaction to something that I've put up
on the screen so it's at one remove but
it's the same sort of feeling that's
that's where the the the drive and the
desire to do that comes from do you
think in order to succeed not just in
the fashion business but just to succeed
generally is is it talent or hard work
it's a combination of both but I would
say it's slanted towards hard work
slanted towards obsession
there are many designers who have much
greater talent as a designer than I do
but they may not have my drive they may
not work as hard they may not have the
focus the desire I mean you have to have
a talent because in the end you can have
all those things and if the pair of
pants you make don't make someone's butt
look good they're not gonna buy them so
you have to have the talent to be able
to make something that people want but
then you also have to have the drive and
the desire to you know sometimes people
are successful because maybe they don't
have that drive but they have someone
around them who takes their raw talent
and pushes them but what you often see
is when not other person steps away
their career can collapse even though
their talent may be immense you said
that when you've been trying to find a
character you look for what comes out of
VR eyes I think I meant that in in
connection to working I don't feel like
I exist until I'm with someone
arnelle's yeah how important is
listening it's everything and it's where
you learn everything and and I always
think of acting I mean when I was
applying to law school and thinking well
this is a stupid acting is a stupid way
to make a living and it doesn't do
anything in the world but I think it
does I think it does and I think it's
there's a great worth in it and the
worth is in listening to people who
maybe don't even exist or who are voices
in your past and through you come
through the work and you give them to
other people and I think that giving
voice to characters that have no other
voice is that's the great worth of what
we do because so much of acting is
vanity so much of this is I mean this
feels so great to come out here and sit
here and have everybody clap but I like
the real thing that makes me feel so
good is when I know I've said something
for a soul you know I've presented a
soul you know for me you know helping a
child get healthcare whose insurance
company has denied his parents the right
to get the treatment that their doctors
say he needs is incredibly important and
it kind of keeps me going because
sometimes the Bharati Oh on the
bureaucracy and the political
back-and-forth prevents positive things
from happening but if you can even help
one person you know it feels like it's
worthwhile how did you make this
perseverance to push through all of this
I don't know man I just did you know I
just that people man my grandma you know
my grandma's one of the biggest
inspirations my mom you know my desire
don't want to give everybody around me a
better life the desire to want to live a
better life man that's just that's my
whole motivation man coming from Detroit
City people don't make it out the west
side of Detroit hey thank you guys so
much for watching I'd love to know what
you thought of the clips which one was
your favorite what impact is it going to
have on your life on your business leave
it in the comments below and I'll join
in the discussion thank you again for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon